could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
opinions to me are the spice of life if
you don't have an opinion there's
something wrong with you i'm peters
morgan uncensored show some damn respect
why do you want to deport me am i
allowed to respond yet i'm a news junkie
and it started when i was six or seven i
mean as i got through my teens i became
very opinionated i read a report last
year said 33 million people in britain
are mentally ill no they're not it's
crap we're spending too much time
encouraging a kind of wallowing in
self-pity people will misunderstand the
use of the word but hang on hang up the
risk i see is being the judge of whether
someone's feelings are worthy of the
emotion
i'm done with this i left on a point of
principle and the principle was i'm
entitled to my opinion why should my
sons be exposed to death threats simply
for being my children cancer culture is
a virus as deadly over time as a
coronavirus the public wants someone to
cancel cancel culture i want to
stimulate debate and to get to some kind
of truth have you ever regretted
anything you've said
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo usa edition i hope
nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
this stephen this is quite quite
interesting you're usually on the uh
i already feel uncomfortable right
i watch your stuff you're forensic you
know you go deep and i'm like i don't
know i don't really know why i'm doing
it other than at least one of my sons is
a massive fan of yours and said daddy
you've got to do this podcast everyone
listens to this podcast so whatever
you're doing
it's working so i'm here you make great
kids well thank you for being here um
the the thing i was thinking thinking
where do i start with this conversation
and honestly the the the center point of
my curiosity is how you came to be the
person you are today and i look through
your story especially your early years
the loss of your father
certain experiences you've had when
you're younger you're a self-aware guy
you're an honest man
what are the factors
at that pre-teen age that went into
making pierce morgan the man that we all
know is this media anomaly i'm a junkie
i'm a news junkie
and it started when i was six or seven
which is just weird i've had four kids
myself the idea of being six or seven
and being addicted to what's happening
in the world to news to newspapers i
used to sit and read the daily mail my
parents used to get the mail i used to
read it from cover to cover when i was
six or seven so from a very early age i
had that kind of
fascination and curiosity with what was
happening and i wanted to know what was
happening and what to think about it i
mean as i got through my teens i became
very opinionated you know to regularly
get thrown at my local pub on a saturday
night for getting drunk and disorderly
disorderly they meant just to opinion
they'd been too loud so i'd argue with
people and then it would get out of hand
and i'd be thrown out i always got
myself back in why why would you argue
with people uh because i used to feel
strongly about stuff you know people see
me hyperventilating about vegan sausage
rolls i think how can any sensible human
being in the world get so enraged by a
vegan sausage roll i don't know except
that when i was young i used to get
enraged by all sorts of things now not
to the point where i'd hit people
or you know
manifest itself in any sort of violence
but i would be
passionate about arguing and most of my
family are the same my grandmother was
very opinionated my mom's very
opinionated my siblings on they're
probably the quiet is one of the three
of us when we go out of all of us um so
opinions to me are the spice of life if
you don't have an opinion there's
something wrong with you to me you've
got to care about what's happening in
the world and you've got to work out
what you think about it and i
particularly think it's important now
and there's so much opinion flying
around that people go to the right
people so that they hear the right kind
of stuff because there's so much
nonsense being spewed into the sort of
twitter sphere and so on on facebook but
that's why i think your show is so
successful your podcast because then
people appreciate the more reasonable
take that you have on things and the way
you try and get to the truth about
people and about things
so
there's on one hand um
loving
to have a discussion and to have your
opinion be heard and and to convey
information and then there's this other
part which i tried to understand which
was you repeatedly said even at 16 and
17 years old that you liked being the
center of attention
so i'm like where does because that
feels like more of a psychological thing
a lot of people don't like being the
same i just wanted to be famous i used
to practice my autograph when i was a
kid why regularly i wanted to be
fabulous i used to collect autographs so
i was a massive cricket fan in
particular me and my brother used to go
and
stand outside pavilions at professional
games and wait for players to come out
and get ian botham's autograph rich's
autograph
and i used to practice mine then i began
writing to world leaders i've got all
these letters from my margaret thatcher
and ted heath when he was prime minister
and world leaders around the world i've
got letters from donald bradman you know
whole shaftland the greatest cricketer
that ever lived i used to just write to
him and used to write back so i used to
spend my entire time in weird
correspondence with the world's most
famous people and quietly thinking to
myself i'd love to be one of these
people must be great center of attention
everyone looking at you talking about
you good bad and ugly so yeah i mean
there are bits of paper at home that my
mum's kept with just endless best wishes
appears morgan best wishes i mean it
sounds ludicrous and extremely vain and
presumptuous of me but now i'm at the
stage where ironically i've got to a
stage where if in the old days i had
this level of recognition i'd be
starting autographs all the time but
nobody wants autographs anymore everyone
wants a selfie
so when i finally got there yeah
actually all the grass had gone out of
fashion it's now selfie time you're very
you're very honest about that a lot of
people wouldn't i don't think
i think 99 of my guests would not have
the whatever to say i wanted to be
famous and by the way most of them are
lying yeah right so i i like to think
that whether you love me or hate me i do
have a kind of brutal honesty about what
i've set out to achieve
what i have achieved what i've failed at
i don't try and sugarcoat things nor do
i try and pretend i'm something i'm not
you know you don't have to like me to
respect the fact i think that i speak my
mind i give honest opinions about stuff
they're not always opinions people agree
with but i want them to be i don't want
people to agree with me necessarily i
want to stimulate debate and to get if
hopefully get to some kind of truth
which is the most important thing in
in a world where truth is so difficult
to find i also wanted to be famous and
i've only really realized this in
hindsight that i definitely wanted to be
famous not for the wrong reasons but i
think the reason i wanted to be famous
is because
it was the antithesis it was the
opposite of what i was sometimes when i
was younger when you're a kid trying to
fit in on the playground only black kid
in an all-white school people calling me
the n-word relaxing my hair to try and
be white like my friends were and i
think i thought fame as
acceptance
on a mass scale so i thought an
admiration so i thought that's what i
wanted when i read about you going to
that comprehensive school
i you were also subjected to quite a
rough treatment yeah well my full name
is piers stefan pugh morgan it's a
double barrel surname imagine having
that name when you go to a local comp
so you know on day one i had the local
skinhead who had a mohican come up and i
think smacked me in the face and that
carried on for quite a while but it
carried on people doing that kind of
thing until my brother jeremy's now a
british army colonel joined the school
and he was like the old thing of mike
tyson you know everyone's got a plan
until they get punched in the face
everyone had a plan about me
until my brother joined and punched him
in the face so i realized then that fall
sometimes it's not a bad thing that when
you're subjected to bullies actually
there's only one language most of them
understand i feel that as i did about
the playground at the time and i feel
about vladimir putin now what's going on
in ukraine it's the same principle when
someone's bullying you either show them
fear and weakness or you stand up to
them did you like school even though you
were both yeah i loved it i went to a
prep school until i was 13. so i had a
lot of privilege at the prep school you
know played sport every day
great academic uh levels and so on i
then went to the local comprehensive
which was a great school great very
successful comprehensive but suddenly
you were playing sport once a week i
realized then the massive gulf
between facilities and resource at a
comprehensive compared to a fee paying
prep school and how that was seemed so
unfair to me but i also discovered that
people
they had chips on their shoulders in
both environments you got the snobs at
the prep school and you got the yobs at
the
comprehensive most people were fine at
both but you got those two types of
people who would have chips on their
shoulders
about in the snobs case looking down on
people in the yobs case hating people
who had more privilege than them i think
i came out of that environment both
environments with quite a healthy you
either have a chip on both shoulders we
have no chip at all i think my ability
to
be exactly the same whether i'm sitting
with nelson mandela and the queen or my
old village mates
comes entirely from that dual pronged
education i had where i saw great
privilege and no privilege and had to
work out a way
of thriving in both environments i think
that was good for me actually if i
removed that experience of that
comprehensive school especially that
before your brother arrived um and saved
you from the bullying per se um what
would if i removed that experience what
would i remove from adult pierce morgan
um i think resilience and mental
strength these are two things i'm
extremely hot about i think this
generation in particular has lost the
ability to look at mental strength and
resilience and triumph over adversity
and being tough in difficult times as
badges of honor they've almost become
badges of shame
where people feel like it's wrong to
have a stiff upper lip to be
strong-minded to be resilient to be
tough under pressure and i looked yes i
was watching the golf the masters tiger
woods
look at tiger woods the story i mean
unbelievable 21 is the greatest golfer
that's ever lived destroying everybody
he has it all he wins 14 majors then he
has one of the greatest falls in the
history of sport and it all involves you
know vegas mayhem and so on and his
world collapses then he has horrific
injuries he becomes number 1100 in the
world he's finished there's a whole
mashup of clips of people saying he's
washed up he's finished he'll never win
again whatever
and there's also a video of him watching
that mashup just after he wins the 2019
masters which no one said he could do
again and again now he has a horrific
car crash you know a year ago and yet
here he is competing in the masters he's
made the cut again the guy is a freak of
nature but he's a freak of mental
strength and i look at him
and i see rocky balboa in mentality and
i look at many other sports stars at the
moment who think it's fine to quit to
give up to walk away to complain all the
time to moan about their lot in life and
i think how have we come to this
how even in high level sport has
quitting now becomes something to
celebrate now it's a contentious issue
and people say you're mocking mental
health when you do this but i don't
think so i think we treat the whole
mental health debate the wrong way i
think we should separate mental health
from mental illness
i don't think mental health is an issue
to even be debated particularly we all
have mental health but if you have a
mental illness you need help you need
treatment right now people are it seems
to me looking at normal life stuff as
some form of mental illness
and anxiety is exploding
people saying they're mentally sick
the incidence of that is exploding how
can that be happening when it's all
we're talking about 24 7. i think we're
going about it the wrong way i think
what we're losing in this debate
is a celebration of resilience and
mental strength i really believe that
and i think i think schools should have
more people in there teaching kids how
to be tougher about how to deal with
normal life stuff and i'm not talking
about people who have clinical
depression or suicidal tendencies or any
of those things those are serious mental
illnesses i'm talking about people who
are
thinking that normal stuff that's
happening in my life which we all have
to go through grief when you lose a
loved one
trouble at work trouble with
relationships whatever it may be
you've got to learn to be more resilient
about these things because that is life
life is rocky balboa said it's it's not
a it's not a better roses
life is tough you know and it's not
about how many times is rock he said to
his son and the famous scene in the
sixth of the franchise when they're that
scene in the street with the spoiled
entitled sun whining away about
everything and rocky turns on him
finally and says look it's not how many
times you
can hit it's how many times you can get
hit get knocked down and get back up and
keep moving forward that is what life's
about
and i don't think
we spend enough time
helping people to be mentally strong and
resilient we're spending too much time
encouraging a kind of wallowing in
self-pity and weakness and it's it is
i'm afraid it's not working demonstrably
not working i remember when you did an
interview with a famous world leader i
think he was a terrorist and you said to
him about his daughter what if your
daughter had dated a jewish yeah
so uh president in the judge of iran
yeah so so the i'll use that same
technique if if one of your children
comes to you and they and they express
some kind of symptom which could either
be a lack of mental resilience or it
could be but they do yeah they do and
how do you know the difference though
well you don't i talk to them yeah and i
talk i try and with all my kids they're
all very different
but they've all come to me at certain
stages with issues they they want help
with
and i always try and drill into them
perspective the great thing you get as
you get older and i'm 57 now
you learn about life good bad and ugly
you learn from mistakes you learn from
stuff that's gone bad in your life
you learn that actually you either give
up or you keep pounding as i keep always
say to them keep pounding just keep
pounding it'll be fine
and it invariably is fine so they start
to realize over time that i'm right that
actually just keep going right don't
give up whatever it is if it's a work
issue if it's an exam issue if it's a
relationship issue whatever it is i have
these conversations all the time on my
kids you know they're like the people i
spend most time talking to and i try and
you know and they all need different
advice and different help in different
ways
but what i try and do is perspective all
the time and based on my own experience
it's like i've been there i've been in
this position it feels like the worst
thing in the world
you know you lose a girlfriend that you
love you lose a job that you love you
you know you crash a car you lose a
family member that you love whatever it
may be
there are all sorts of things that will
come and test you especially as you get
older you lose your first friend who
dies when you're young i can remember
losing one of my closest friends before
he was even 30. devastating absolutely
devastating but when it happens again
and again with people that you care
about you realize that's life life is
what it is you have one life and people
die and people you love die and people
you care about die
and you've got to learn to ride that
that wave of grief and it's not mental
illness
it's not anxiety
it's
actually just something we all have to
deal with but too much i think too many
young people today
feel unnaturally anxious about these
things as they did about the pandemic or
about the war in ukraine an interesting
conversation i had with dr phil
out here in america actually about this
who said when he was young he gave the
analogy when he was young if
someone was eaten by a crocodile on a
golf course in florida very unlikely
that anyone would know that outside of
the immediate area
you know there were very few as one or
two
main television news bulletins a day
there were very few national newspapers
most state or county newspapers
and so it might get reported in the
local paper that would be it but
certainly nobody outside of florida
would likely ever hear about that the
difference now is
young people will see the video of the
person being eaten by the crocodile
within 20 minutes of it happening
quite likely someone will have got it on
a camera on their phone so they're being
exposed all the time to a sensory
overload of quite grim stuff ukraine is
a very good example
of the first time really we've had a war
of this kind where we're all watching it
in real time
unfurl on social media we're seeing all
the videos we're seeing the horror in
real first hand
exposure and that has to have an effect
on your senses it has to increase your
anxiety levels i get all that um you
know my grandmother was 19 in world war
ii when it started 25 when it ended she
didn't see all this stuff you just
didn't get exposed to it but if she had
been it would have probably had a
devastating effect on her so i think
that
i have sympathy with this generation i
think in many ways they're a great
generation they're better informed than
any previous generation i think that
these
networks like instagram facebook twitter
and so on they've certainly given people
an amazing connection with each other
but they've also got this terrible fomo
which has been created which i see the
first time with my kids one of their
summer and all their mates are somewhere
else all they're seeing is all the fun
going on on instagram
and it makes them a bit
anxious
i never had that i didn't know what my
friends were doing in the next village
so things have changed technology's
changed it's good in one way it can be
bad in other ways and we've got to work
out a way to help
young people but ultimately i come back
to
i don't want to be unsympathetic
certainly i want to help
but i do think we're going about it the
wrong way i think we're encouraging or
wallowing we're celebrating self-pity
we're celebrating victimhood in a way
that everybody now is like you see stuff
on twitter like you know i've just
failed my driving test for the fourth
time but i'm so proud of myself for the
journey i've gone on what are you
talking about
which means you're proud of yourself you
just failed you're driving desperately
thought let's be proud of i get that
part the bit that i i still i'm still
struggling to get on board with is
having sat here with even i know you
know roman kemp yeah and his love
right having sat here with roman kemp
and hearing this what he went through
with his his friend who was on his radio
station with him i'm very aware of that
yeah killed himself out of the blue yes
and never spoke to anyone and roman said
if i'd lined up 20 of my friends and
said which one is suicidal he would have
been named last yeah in my estimation so
when i reflect on that and i i look at
male suicides in particular and a lot of
what the mental health organizations say
the causes of that one of them is that
men just don't talk about how they're
feeling and then that results in
alcoholism and these are but i do talk
about it yeah and i do encourage people
so this is what i'm saying so when
someone says the use of the word
wallowing that sounds very similar it
depends what they're wallowing in if
they're wallowing in
but you know when you use those words
yes
you know because you're a smart man and
you you you write you know that people
will
misunderstand the use of the word and
there's harm in them that's them
misunderstanding what i mean by it okay
it's a bit like the debate about obesity
we're now at the ludicrous stage of this
debate we're not allowed to call people
fat
you're not allowed to it's offensive
so we now have a situation where you see
a 310 pound model on the cover of
cosmopolitan who's five foot two she's
dangerously morbidly obese but the cover
the picture and the interview six pages
inside never mentions that it celebrates
her body positive image nothing body
positive about being morbidly obese
she's going to die if she's enabled in
this way going forward i'm not afraid to
say that and there's a society that
doesn't go there
and pretends that this is all perfectly
acceptable is doing that woman an
incredible disservice so when you say
well you can't use the word wallowing
but i would say to you stephen i didn't
say that because you're implying it yeah
yeah
because i would say to you a lot of
people do wallow i see them what's the
difference between wallowing and coming
to a friend and saying i'm feeling
really or even tweeting it so i'm
feeling like there's something wrong
with me what's the difference between
wallowing well there's a line i don't
know i know exactly what the line is but
i do know when friends or family members
come to me
either they come to me with something
where i think yeah they've got a valid
reason to feel this way or sometimes you
just got to go
get over it and then they might laugh
and have a drink and they get over it i
think by the way you're not allowed to
say that anymore there'll be people
watching this your younger audience will
be going oh my god did you just tell
people to get over it it's all about
people with mental illness no i'm not no
i'm not be very careful that you listen
to what i'm saying i distinguish between
people who i believe have mental illness
and people who i believe are genuinely
wallowing because society has decided
that it wants to celebrate people who
have something wrong with them more than
it celebrates now people who are
successful and tough achievers and talk
about having grit and stiff upper lip
and all these things that's all become
sticks to beat people with i have it
used against me a day you talk about a
stiff upper lip why shouldn't i
why shouldn't i i have a stiff upper lip
i've been through a lot of crap in my
life and i've decided that that's the
way i deal with it you may not like it
and maybe you like to deal with it by
going woe is me and one of my favorite
poems is a uh d.h lawrence poem called
about self-pity it's only three or four
lines
and it says a wild thing never feels
sorry for itself
a bird will die frozen
on a bow of a tree before it feels
self-pity or something like that it's a
brilliant poem so that's it it's only
about four lines
and i get that point is in the in the
jungle in the world of animals self-pity
doesn't exist
wallowing in your own woe doesn't exist
you've got to get on with it you know
one of my favorite conversations ever
with with sir roger bannister who sadly
died but he was the first man to break
the four-minute mile
and he i asked him he used to live in
the square i live in london and he came
to one of the 200th anniversary of the
square and i had a chat with him and i
said did you only you know when you won
this amazingly killed it collapsed at
the line i said did you have any sort of
motivational quote that drove you and he
went funny enough he said i have one it
was an anonymous proverb from the
african bush
and it was when a lion wakes up in the
morning
it knows one thing it has to run faster
than the slowest gazelle or it won't eat
and when a gazelle wakes up in the
morning it knows it has to run faster
than the slowest line or it's going to
get killed
so whatever you are in the african bush
one thing's for sure
when the sun comes up you better start
running
and that motivated him and it's a great
quote and i think it's a great quote for
all your
viewers listeners in this podcast to
take away from this interview if you
take one thing away
get running get moving
be positive don't let normal life stuff
drag you down because if it does it will
dominate your life and you'll become one
of those sort of miserable
self-obsessed people in the wrong way
where all you're thinking about is you
and your problems and your woes it's
like there are a lot of people a lot
worse off than you when i see some of
the crap i'm watching at the moment on
social media of people feeling sorry for
themselves when you see what's happening
in ukraine it actually makes me puke
it's like watch what's happening to the
people of ukraine and get a perspective
about your life and i'm sorry if that
sounds tough but i'm not sorry actually
i get you i completely get the point
about mental resilience and i think
there's so much of what you said that i
really agree with especially about a
younger generation i'm
i've said on this podcast many times i
am scared of over labeling things things
that might just be a bad mood or
whatever with something else which is
much more medically um concerning and
when i asked that question then you said
it depends what it is yeah in terms of a
friend coming to you with mental health
disorder the problem is
you'll know that these things are so
subjective so
when uh when someone comes like people
could genuinely be suicidal genuinely be
suicide not well faking or looking for
attention over
losing a cryptocurrency investment i
read an article about that the other day
guy's crypto investment goes down kills
himself
so i i the risk i see is being the judge
of whether someone's feelings are worthy
of the the emotion
that's the risk it's like
you know like i think there are because
there are millions of people out there
prepared to
do what you're talking about i i'm a
very rare voice
in the public platform arena who's
prepared to give a slightly different
perspective on this stuff and to me
there's room for both of us you know you
don't need any more people who are going
to give 24 7 coverage to mental health
as an issue as
on the assumption we're all slightly
mentally ill i just don't buy it i read
i read a report last year said 33
million people in britain are mentally
ill no but not
it's crap
crap and when when a society pretends
that is the case
because a lot of people are identifying
as mentally ill when actually they just
have anxiety about exams or
relationships or whatever it may be
when we do that it means the people who
really need help are not getting it it
means they're slipping through the
cracks in my opinion
and that's the problem with it
um and you know it's not about being
callous or insensitive my i think my
kids would tell you i spent hours and
hours
sometimes talking through problems with
them but always i come back to look
life's tough and you've got to keep
pounding that's my mantra
because this one i've applied to myself
and my family have had a lot of stuff to
deal with and they've kept pounding
because what's the alternative really
the alternatives you give up
and that to me is not an option
not an option that would bring me any
pleasure couldn't look in the mirror
having just given up all the time why
would why would that bring anyone
pleasure
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast for many years
people have been asking for a coffee
flavoured huel and quite recently he'll
release the iced coffee caramel flavor
of their um ready to drink heels and
i've just become hooked on it over the
last couple of weeks i've been on a
really interesting journey with huel
which i've described and talked about a
little bit on this podcast i started
with the berry ready to drink then i
moved over to the protein salted caramel
because it's 100 calories and it gives
you all of your essential vitamins and
minerals but also gives you the 20 odd
grams of protein you need and now i'm
balanced between them both i drink
mostly the banana flavor ready to drink
i've got really into the iced coffee
caramel flavor of heels ready to drink
and now i'm drinking that as well as the
protein make sure you try the new ready
to drink flavors that the caramel flavor
is amazing the new banana flavor as well
is amazing and obviously as i said the
iced coffee caramel flavor has been a
real smash here so check it out let me
know what you think on social media i
see all of your tags and instagram posts
and tweets about you
back to the podcast
one of the things that i love about your
um well i was really compelled by by
your story as i read through your early
professional career was clearly for some
reason which i couldn't figure out from
just reading
you got a head quite quickly
kelvin gave you a shot yeah at the sun
rupert murdoch gave you a shot at news
of the world when you were 28 he made
you the the editor of the largest
newspaper in the western hemisphere if
i'm not correct 28 years old so when i
was reading that i i thought i've got to
ask him
why
what was it about you well i think that
i remember alex ferguson saying i know
you're a big united fan of my sympathies
at this different time i remember him
saying that he loved youth because there
was a fearlessness of youth i think i
was quite fearless in my 20s certainly
you know before you get responsibility
before you get married you have kids and
so on you get other people you're
responsible for there's a fearlessness
that comes with youth and i think i had
that certainly it was instilled by
the confidence came from my family very
strong women in particular in my family
my mum my grandmother tremendously
strong people who come through a lot of
adversity um never wallowed in self-pity
to quote the awful phrase i know drives
you mad
but they never did and that was just not
allowed it was always like just get on
with it dust yourself down get on with
it and i like that to be honest i
thrived under that mantra and i remember
kelvin mckenzie was a mercurial genius
in many many ways
brutal but brilliant you know hilarious
and barbaric i mean he's like everything
but the sun had an amazing power and
voice when he was in charge of it
and
he said the most annoying thing about me
was that he could give me the most
savage bollocking where literally his
sort of neck
veins would start to explode
and within an hour i'd bounce back into
his office
bouncing with excitement because i had a
scoop for him and i was completely
unfazed by the bollocking it had
motivated me to go and prove him wrong
and get and get a good story i think
that's how people should be in life
i think it's a shame that in the
workplace now you're not allowed to
raise your voice
you're not allowed to it's bullying
everyone's a victim of bullying you
can't have any banter anymore can't be
fun
all the joy's been sucked out of life by
this woke brigade of
in my view awful people
who just think that life should be
humorous
banterless
uh everything is bullying every
criticism is bullying
everything is terrible people are awful
you can't have fun you can't do anything
i don't buy it it's not what most people
are like
most people aren't like that they don't
actually believe the crap they're coming
out with they don't it's not how anybody
wants to lead their lives we know from
the pandemic what it's like when our
freedom our basic freedom gets taken
away why would we come out of a pandemic
would we want to lead a joyless
existence how do we fix this because i
agree with you i i think that common
sense has to come into play i think the
problem with the the woke council
culture as i put it is if you go and
study i read a whole book about this
last year it was a massive bestseller
because people understood it right so i
think you know where i come from
probably politically we're not that far
apart from each other i guess from what
i know about you um but i i want to
study the origin of the word woke and
what it meant i by that definition i'm
woke
i believe in promoting
uh campaigns against racial and social
injustice i've done it all my career as
a newspaper editor and as a television
broadcaster you know i've done that it
doesn't cut the ice though with the
modern word brigade because they've
stolen
wokery and they've now used it as a new
form of fascism
where they want to dictate to people how
they lead their lives what they can find
funny
what movies are acceptable are not
acceptable what television shows they
can enjoy you know what haircuts they
can have that aren't inappropriate or
cultural inappropriation you can't
celebrate any other culture anymore it's
all inappropriate every joke is
inappropriate every comedian has to be
cancelled people can't host the oscars
if they told a inappropriate joke 10
years before
uh yet roman polanski was given an oscar
after he raped a child i mean the sort
of warp morality of all this
is absolutely extraordinary to me but at
its center a woman came up to me in
kensington
a few months ago after the markle
debacle as i call it and she said she
said mr morgan i'm an 80 year old
australian woman but don't hold either
of those things against me i meant to
laugh on the streets he said the trouble
with these wokies is they want to suck
all the joy out of life and i thought
what a brilliant way of describing it
and they've literally become the very
fascists that they profess to hate most
and we have to counter it and so my
ambition with my new show for example is
to cancel cancer culture to go back to
what a democracy should be to what
society should be when it's supposedly
democratic where you and i can have a
spirited debate about something and
agree to disagree and go and have a beer
or maybe we reach points of consensus to
what used to happen i've had ferocious
arguments with my friends and family my
entire life the idea i would disown them
as you see happening all the time now
with people falling out with friends and
family because they're so blindly
self-righteous about their own opinion
that they can't tolerate another opinion
the idea we have university campuses
where
only one certain type of voice is
tolerated at a university a place you're
supposed to learn all sorts of disparate
views hear all different voices and make
your own mind up now no unless they're
woke speakers no one else is allowed if
you're a conservative which by the way
many millions of people are in this
country in america and australia if
you're a conservative you are the enemy
to be crushed and destroyed and no
platformed really
how do we get there
how could any student
have their mind developed or evolved in
an environment that cancels anybody
for deviating from a woke agenda
it's
madness
you know and when i look at what's
happening with the transgender debate i
support transgender rights to fairness
and equality i always have publicly in
columns on television
on twitter
i've been very clear i want transgender
people to have equality and fairness
right to the point where trans activism
leads to an erosion of women's rights as
we're seeing all over the place not
least in the world of sport if anybody
genuinely wants to sit here and say to
me that what's going on in women's sport
with transgender athletes is fair or
equal
i'd love to listen to it because it's
[ __ ]
we all know it's unfair and what's being
caught in the crosshairs of this is that
many trans people who don't want to get
involved in this debate and just want to
be able to go about their lives and try
and have a life of fairness and equality
they're getting subjected to mockery and
ridicule
because it's so ridiculous what's going
on
with
transport
and so i say to people yeah you can say
to me you're bigoted and you're
transphobic but i'm not
i'm actually just the voice of common
sense when you see even jk rowling
cancelled because she believes in the
biology of sex
it's just madness
sex is not something you can just
pretend like gender it could be anything
you make up on the spur of the moment it
can't be
you you've seen how this is
got progressively more let's say the
world has got progressively more work
i think
the world has moved from being
woke
right okay by the original i think that
most people in the 60s 70s and 80s
wanted to see better
racial equality and social equality
most people
but that's what the original definition
of woke was the modern day woke is
nothing to do with that the modern day
woke is a form of fascism okay so you
will abide by our rules or you get
destroyed that's the difference to me so
the world has got more of this modern
day wokism yeah right um and it's i i've
seen it on social media the way that
algorithms work as well they show you
more of the same they keep reinforcing
you then they then because you build an
audience of the same people they clap
more when you say a certain thing yes
kind of reinforcement you appreciate
your choir yeah you know i i i you know
geologies
you go about two thousand years we lived
in tribes yeah that's written in your
book yeah right and i told the story you
never used to come out of your tribe so
everyone in the tribe would look the
same same attitudes eat the same food
drink the same drink same senses of
humor because you never moved out of
this group of people
and then people began to move out of
their tribes and meet other tribes who
dress differently thought differently
laughed at different things maybe spoke
differently and both tribes in that
moment decided the only answer to this
was to kill each other
well that's where we've gone back to are
you optimistic that not really no so
this is what i wanted to say is your
antidote for this new workism is to lead
and to create a counter narrative which
is what you're doing with your new show
piece you haven't centered what you did
with your book as well are you
optimistic deeply that that will win
well let me ask you a question so i'm
i'm described as highly controversial
right i've been called all sorts of
names people say that what i say things
i say are outrageous
when you read my book how many times did
you stop and think that's outrageous no
i didn't really disagree with anything
right so that's my point i don't think
i'm the controversial one well so i
think i come at this from a reasonably
common scenario i didn't disagree with
you at all because you were talking
about things like populism and
liberalism and how it's changed i
completely agree i think i used to
identify as being on the left now i
don't because the the
the because they're nuts a lot of them
yeah a lot of it is absolutely nuts i
also don't really identify with being on
the right either because they're nuts i
agree
i find myself you get nuts on both sides
and we're moving to the extremities but
i'll get cancelled from both sides yes
because i don't wear the football kit of
either i'm the same yeah so i want to
bring back a more
consensus related society
where consensus where you reach points
of agreement through debate and you
don't try and
shame or cancel each other by having
different opinions
because that's at the core of this you
know they call themselves liberals
they're not liberal liberalism isn't
about
an inability to tolerate other opinions
it's the opposite
you're supposed to tolerate and respect
other opinions
and agree to disagree we've lost this in
society because a small group of people
but very vocal and very angry about
everything all the time
they are driving an agenda which if we
go down that road we'll be the end of a
democratic society as we know it so i
see my self
humbly as
trying to defend democracy genuinely
and humility is not something that comes
naturally to me but genuinely trying to
defend what democracy really is and
trying to educate these
wokies about what real liberalism is
what democracy actually means what free
speech means free speech is not about
you in an echo chamber all agreeing with
each other as churchill said free speech
is about listening to views you just
don't agree with but allowing people to
have different views
you're you know it's funny i i went
around the world when i was running my
marketing business um before i resigned
and i used to have one slide on my
presentation deck that had your face on
it
and do you know who else's face was on
that same slide deck i went all around
the world with this presentation with
apple amazon i had pierce morgan
katie hopkins kanye west and donald
trump and i used to tell people that
this a very important thing to learn
from these four people because whether
you like them or not
in marketing the least profitable
outcome is indifference when you don't
carry either way and people have an
opinion it's funny because
you know i was talking to the girls on
my team here yesterday and they don't
always agree with you but they're always
listening yeah and sometimes you know on
the covered issues or this issue they'll
be behind you and then they'll be
against you but do you realize
strategically
um the art of being the sen being the
center of conversation yes and and what
are the principles
if if it's a brand trying to be relevant
or the center of attention or if it's a
person in their personal brand for you
what are the principles for one to
replicate what you've done with that
confidence confidence in yourself
self-belief yeah i think the one thing i
have is a lot of self-belief i'm i'm
firm i remember a friend of mine kevin
peterson the cricketer his big mantra
with himself when he played cricket for
england was back yourself back yourself
whoever you're facing he was one of the
few players in history to demolish shane
warm at his peak in the 2005 ashes
series because he backed himself but
it's smashing it's risky we've seen from
your cause it's risky but as wayne
gretzky the greatest ice hockey player
in history
said brilliantly you'll miss a hundred
percent of the shots you don't take
you've got to take risks in life you've
got to learn from failure mars the
confectioners used to celebrate
chocolate bars that didn't work more
than they did chocolate bars that worked
they worked on the assumption that most
of their bars would work they tested
them tested and tested and knew what
they were doing so most of their
new bars would would work but if they
occasionally had a failure out of
nowhere stunned everyone they would
celebrate that because they reckon they
learn more from the failure than they
did from the endless success and i agree
i've learned more from failures and
success success is easy
when you're successful everyone must
have a piece of the pie and i've had
great success and i've had
wonderfully you know cataclysmic moments
of doing
and when you get the doing the old
cliche you find out who your friends are
is completely true you find out who your
friends are you find out who actually
cares about you who's prepared to stand
up for you
you know i remember
after my dramatic departure from good
morning britain sharon osbourne
tweeting uh that i was entitled to my
opinion
she knew by doing that there could be
massive repercussions for her given how
incendiary the whole debate was it cost
her a job
scandalously
scandalously she was described as a
racist sympathizer
on her show the talk but when she asked
them to describe what racist things i'd
said they weren't able to do so because
guess what i'd said nothing racist
nothing i thought about mega market was
driven by
anything to do with her race or skin
color why would it be
i just thought she was a disingenuous
piece of work smearing the royal family
i'm entitled to that opinion you may not
agree with it i think most people who
watch the interview probably ended up
agreeing with me it doesn't really
matter whether you agree or not but the
idea that sharon osborne was destroyed
at the altar of
cancel culture
because she had the audacity to say i
was entitled to an opinion not that she
even agreed with my opinion
just that i was entitled to one
that in that moment said to me
how ridiculous this culture has got
ridiculous and i'm delighted that sharon
is now going to be back on talk tv in
the uk
in the show after mine on a show called
the talk
she's going to be uncanceled by us
because she should never have been
cancelled in the first place and when
people say counseling doesn't exist look
at what happened to sharon look at the
effect it had on her and her family
devastating she couldn't get a job in
america where she'd worked for 40 years
so it's going on and i i want to cancel
that culture i think it's wrong so so
one of so that led to the first point
there was confidence in backing yourself
yes i think the other thing you've got
to have a bit of bravado a bit of
hutzpah
you've got to have an ability to know
how to stir things up and wind people up
i like to annoy all the right people who
are so permanently offended by
everything they're easy to wind up do i
enjoy that yes i love sometimes just
putting a tweeter i mean the vegan
sausage roll debate was one of the
funniest things ever i had the flu on
holiday in italy i was in bed sweating
with a raging fever and i saw greg
saying the wait is over
finally it's here the vegan sausage
right so what on earth are you talking
about who's been waiting for a vegan
sausage roll apart from anything else
like brew with the french where it's
illegal to market
uh vegetarian or vegan products using
meat language a sausage roll is meat
if vegans want to eat their gruel fine
go and have a joyless existence munching
your lentils don't take my language
don't pretend your sausage rolls are
real sausage rolls they're not and
they're tasteless and they've got more
calories than mcdonald's cheeseburgers
so my point is
do i care look i don't care as much as i
do about ukraine
but in the moment it really annoyed me
that there was a presumption we'd all
been waiting for a vegan sausage roll
and i was also annoyed that you were
seeing stories of
vegans charging into state restaurants
and playing music of cows being killed
it's like shut up and go away i don't
come into your gruel restaurant
ever and shout about what you do to the
bee community in california when you eat
your almonds and almond milk right
billions of bees exterminated every year
in a six week cull in california so
vegans can eat almonds and eat avocados
but do you care about vegan sausage
rolls uh i care about the hypocrisy that
surrounds the debate actually so anyway
i did a tweet saying this is ridiculous
and
and everyone went nuts i wasn't allowed
to think that this was ridiculous i had
to agree that vegan sausage rolls are
fantastic everyone goes bonkers
greg's love it because they sell i think
about a billion dollars worth more of
their products that year in fact the ceo
thanked me personally at the end of year
results so they cleaned up in fact i'm
thinking about going to a business where
all i do is take big checks from
companies to attack their products and
probably make a fortune and but the
whole thing to show me that everyone was
allowed to love vegan sausage rolls but
if you deviated from that and said you
hated them you had to be destroyed this
wasn't acceptable
the work brigade decided vegan sausage
rolls were untouchable you had to
support them you had to think they were
great this was brilliant even though
they're bad for you
literally worse for you than a
mcdonald's cheeseburger uh in terms of
salt and calorie intake
and even though the whole thing was
predicated on this utter hypocrisy
around vegan food that somehow they're
leaving the little the animals alone
when they exterminate the little guys
the bees and i feel sorry for the bees
no one ever hear vegans talk about bees
here it's always the big animals they
care about cows not the little guys i'm
a little guy
i'm the robin hood of this debate i look
after the little guys against the
sheriffs of nottingham sure
well i think about that so okay you play
that you play you know i know from what
you've said here you know that it's part
of it is a game and it's a very
profitable it's all fun right to a point
but there's also a serious point behind
it which is that actually
the vegan
food business is a massively burgeoning
business and that's fine people want to
eat that that's fine but i do agree with
the french that actually you shouldn't
be allowed to
pretend what you're doing is meat
related because it's not so there's a
genuine point there which i do feel
quite strongly about the french have
made it illegal you can't use meat
language to sell vegan products i think
we should go the same way you have your
world and we'll have ours you know your
career has been pretty filled with these
moments of like where you are the center
the orbit of sort of you know
debate and controversy controversy when
you go for a period and people aren't
tweeting at your abuse and stuff and
they're not kicking off do you feel a
little bit like [ __ ] was i've made a
mistake i remember donald trump telling
me when he got to the white house he put
four tvs in his bedroom i used to wake
up in the morning at five o'clock
because he doesn't sleep
and he'd look at the tvs and if he
didn't like what was on the screen or if
it wasn't about him he'd just pull his
phone out and tweet something and next
thing they'd all change in real time
breaking news president trump says blah
blah blah and i kind of related to that
it's like i wake up in the morning and
i'm not trending it's like there's a
problem and i have to deal with it so
yeah look i'm in the opinion business
it's very lucrative for me i make a lot
of money out of it i get a lot of
notoriety and fame out of it people love
me or hate me but you know that's
part of being in the opinion business if
you don't want to be
loved and hated
then you don't express opinions about
anything and that way to me madness lies
you know i'd much rather be it's like
the old again churchill uh you know he
said that
if you've got enemies it means at some
stage in your life you stood up for
something that you believe in good
that's good
when you've had those you you called
them catastrophic events in your life
where you know
and well other people see them as
catastrophic i've never really seen it
that way myself like when i got fired
from the mirror for example yeah after
10 years other people were far more
agitated about that and thought it was
far more characterism than i did the
mirror good morning britain and this was
the other thing about your story which i
found really i wanted to ask you about
is you have these these ups and then
these downs and these ups and these
downs and your twitter bio i think is
probably quite an an apt um
summary of of maybe your views on this
which is i can't remember exactly but
one day of the cockpit one day you're
the [ __ ] of the war next to feather
duster yeah so
and then i read that you know after like
the mirror situation you slept a lot
yeah
and then and then also it seems that
after every firing or push getting
pushed out whatever you go and get
pissed no
again churchill who i love as you may
have gathered again churchill who's now
being reviled by the white brigade of
course because he saved the world from
nazi germany so of course he has to be
destroyed
but churchill you know he he also said
that the best definition of success is
going from failure to failure with no
discernible loss of enthusiasm now i
think i've had a lot of success and
occasional failure but i don't look upon
any of the downs in the same way that
other people do about my career i'm very
relaxed about my level of success and
failure i think it's all been greased to
the mill
normally i've left somewhere in
explosive circumstances and it's lit to
something better invariably so i'm very
optimistic about it my glasses always
are full i think that one chapter ending
is another chapter about to start you
just have to make sure you get something
good
if i spoke to your wife i mean even your
kids and i said how does pierce's
emotional state change after in one of
these moments of catastrophic
failure getting kicked out
they'd say what i'm saying
he doesn't change at all barely at all
barely at all no i don't i don't i
probably if anything i'm more relaxed
that's all because when you're in one of
these cauldron jobs editing a daily
newspaper or doing a morning tv show you
know and you've got the adrenaline
whirring and you're caffeined up and so
on it makes you slightly wired to be
around when you're not doing that you're
more relaxed i'm probably just calmer a
bit more relaxed and then that gets a
bit boring and i want to get back in the
game again because in that in that gap
between one job and the next that you've
had many of those those gaps what's
going on in your life and how are you
not because it must be very easy for you
to just to rush into something else the
next day yeah but the gap between you
leaving good morning britain i always
advise people
when they lose a big job take your time
just go and clear your head
you'll get offered loads of things but
don't react to it let the dust settle
you know i left good morning britain it
was a massive global firestorm uh and i
just took my time i had loads of people
offering me stuff every day
all sorts of jobs from around the world
could have taken any one of them
uh but actually i thought i'm gonna take
my time just chill
watch some football watch some cricket
see some friends
uh get fit you know unfortunately then
got covered and that was the end of the
fitness camp over a few months but the
the principle is clear your head you get
these moments a few times in your life
where you get a chance to reset
recalibrate clear your head and then
work out what you really want to do next
because it won't be the same thing three
or four months down the line as it feels
in the moment most people's tendencies
when they leave a big job in dramatic
circumstances i've got to do the same
thing somewhere else
prove my point i don't feel i need to
prove anything to anybody you know i was
a talent show judge for six years loved
it number one show on british tv and
american tv for six years great then i
left
i i just couldn't think of any more
things to say about piano playing pigs
it's time to move on you know i did
larry king's job at cnn after him for
nearly four years i did 1200 shows on
prime time cnn around the world people
call it a failure it's like well that's
1200 more than any other british person
i've seen do a prime time talk show in
america so it's all about it's all
relative isn't it about what your
perception of failure is had a great
time in cnn and actually i wanted to
come home i then did breakfast tv which
i never thought i'd ever want to do or
even enjoy i loved it and we absolutely
crushed it we took the ratings from a 14
share to 36 share they've now gone back
to 18. so people could do the maths you
know i think it was a massive success
and yeah i still meet some people go uh
yeah all went wrong for you didn't i
said not really no no it was a brilliant
success good morning britain uh we
became the number one
breakfast show in the country on my last
day
i left on a point of principle and the
principle was i'm entitled to my opinion
you may not like it i'm entitled to my
opinion and in each case where i've had
a career-ending sort of moment it's
really been where the bosses have lost
their bottle with me
so i need i've now gravitated back to my
first big boss in the media rupert
murdoch who's got balls of steel
and he's not going to take a phone call
from meghan markle demanding my head on
a plane
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast as we all know
energy independence and living a little
greener has never been more important
for a better future it's a journey i've
been on over the last couple of years
that i've shared with you sporadically
ever since i sold my range over sport
and bought an electric bicycle and
there's a lot of people out there that
listen to this podcast that are looking
to make that sustainable switch in the
things that run their daily life whether
it's their home their car their vehicles
whatever it might be so when a good
friend of mine at a company called my
energy called jordan told me she was
interested in sponsoring this podcast i
jumped at the opportunity so for those
of you that don't know my energy are a
uk renewable energy brand whose mission
is to increase the usage of green energy
helping people like you and i to save
time and money when it comes to making
sustainable switches in our lives so if
this resonates with you and you're the
type of person that's been looking or
thinking about going on your own
sustainability journey i highly
recommend checking them out at
meghan
myenergy.com
right not going to go into the issues of
that i'm really not personally that
interested in it but what i was i didn't
want to ask you as i saw when you spoke
oxford they you were talking about
jeremy clarkson getting in a fist fight
with him yeah going down the pub making
up after and there you said i do like to
fall out with someone in the makeup
again yeah
what would it take for you and meghan
markle
to make up
she could do she did an interview like
this with me be very interesting
you know it's like meghan markle to me
has lost all sense of reality about life
she needs to sit with someone like me
not an oprah winfrey enabling interview
fueling your victimhood she needs
someone to give her some perspective i
talk to her about perspective
where i say you know you are you aware
that when you preach to us about climate
change and the environment and carbon
footprint from elton john's private
plane
it doesn't sit very well are you aware
that when you tweet as they did on the
day of her half a million dollar baby
shower in new york with all her
celebrity friends
when you tweet from your twitter account
about poverty it doesn't sit very well
are you aware that when you preach about
equality from your 11 million california
mansion it doesn't sit very well are you
aware that when you rip our beloved
prince away from the bosom of his family
and take him to america and woke him
into submission it doesn't sit very well
with the british people are you aware
that when you make
very serious allegations of racism and
callous disregard for suicidal thoughts
you actually have to produce some
evidence to support it otherwise
everyone at the palace and the royal
family gets smeared by association with
those comments is she aware of any of
those things i don't know but i'd love
to ask those questions she didn't get
asked them by oprah oprah's went what
what what repeatedly
just believed everything she said we now
know at least 17 statements that meghan
markle made in that interview were false
so am i still supposed to believe her
is it a job-ending moment if i don't
believe her so i think she's a piece of
work
i think she i was one of many people
that she used along her
her path up the slippery ladder that's
fine i don't care he met her once
but the way she treated me on a very
small level is not dissimilar the way
she disowned her father the guy that
brought her up on his own for six seven
years
you know he got disowned he lived 70
miles away she never sees him he's ever
met his son-in-law i miss crazy stuff
right she had one member of her entire
family at the wedding
where her family should have been on
either side was oprah winfrey and george
clooney do me a favor
so i see right through it people still
want to believe her that's fine people
love meghan markle think what's happened
to harry is great that's fine too i just
don't agree
and i'm afraid you have to respect my
right to have that opinion um i'm
getting about as bored with it as you
are to be honest with you yeah so i
don't want to be defined by meghan
markle even though she was personally
responsible for me losing a job that i i
loved
you know she was the one who wrote to
the boss of itv
on the monday night that led to me
leaving the next day
um
talking about being we're both women and
we're both mothers you've got to get rid
of him do people think that's right
is it right that uh
that a
person like meghan markle from the
california mansion should leave her a
british television broadcaster out of a
job he's enjoying that viewers are
enjoying him doing in that way i don't
think so is it right that my right to
free speech was so impinged that i had
to leave a job if i didn't apologize for
disbelieving someone who said false
things i don't think so i thought the
whole thing was ridiculous as did ofcom
the government regulated months later
who ruled in my favor so i thought the
whole thing frankly was preposterous but
in answer to your original question
let's do an interview megan let me put
all these questions to you and answer
some difficult questions
because i don't wish them harm i don't
wish them to be unhappy but i hate what
they've done between them to the royal
family and the monarchy i think it's
been incredibly damaging do you ever do
you ever get concerned that on a real
human level that some of the words you
say
say for megan or sam smith or on good
morning britain or even around i know is
it tessa who was the front cover of the
magazine yeah the the cosmo covergirl
cover do you ever has it ever crossed
your mind that the words or tweets might
actually
hurt someone do you think it's crossed
did you well has it across meghan
markle's mind
what she did to me you know like on the
suicide megan i didn't cost her a job
you know
she was saying she was suicidal
again i don't want to go back to the
point of mental health but did you ever
like think
is this going to
hurt this person on it she she said that
two people at the palace when she told
them she had suicidal thoughts said she
couldn't get treatment
because it would be damaging to the
brand yeah i don't believe that and no
evidence has been brought forward to
support it those are extremely
incendiary allegations in my view
weaponizing mental health and suicide
to portray yourself as a victim if
meghan markle has proof
that two senior members of the royal
household refused to let her get help
for suicidal thoughts i want to know who
they were
when they said it and they shouldn't
have those jobs
but we are now
a year and a bit later
no evidence similarly with her racism
claims one of them we knew immediately
was untrue it's completely untrue that
her son
was prevented from being a prince
because of his skin color demonstrably
untrue
factually wrong and the other claim was
that a member of the royal family
expressed concern about archie's skin
color who was it and what did they say
and what was the context in which they
said it because the damage that she
calls by calling the royal family a
bunch of racists is incalculable as we
saw on the recent tour of the caribbean
with william and kate so i don't think
it's i don't think it's harsh
to want some evidence to support such
incendiary claims and when it comes to
do i use tough language yes sometimes i
think i do
but i don't regret doing that because i
think they've been using pretty
despicable language themselves have you
ever regretted anything you've said in
terms of sometimes you think oh i mean
sometimes no i encourage all my kids to
be free thinkers and sometimes they'll
be on me you know like dad you went too
far you shouldn't say that and we'll
have a spirited debate about it and
sometimes they they change my mind about
stuff tell me one example i knew that
i tried to think it has happened
it has happened i mean they'll be saying
that my middle son stanley is an actor
and photographer
he loves your podcast he's my favorite
son yeah exactly he's like oh he's on
mine all right i have all my sons of the
same and my daughter um
but he would say now that's talking
about meghan markle yeah just don't
bother don't and he's right there comes
a point what's the point the problem is
they make themselves
newsworthy all the time my job is to
talk about the news and obviously have a
vested interest in
the mark called debacle because it cost
me my job so i still feel that i have a
sort of involvement in that in that
story but he would certainly be saying
that move on to other stuff
you know just do something else in this
interview that's more interesting than
megan bloody markle and he's right
actually
so that would be an example i've had
that conversation with him and my other
sons but we argue we have we have a
what's up group me and my sons if people
read that or they laugh because they
hammer me my kids about all sorts of
stuff sometimes we agree a lot of the
time we don't agree and we have
really vociferous arguments but then we
all go out there and have fun together
and that's the way it should be i want
my kids to be independent-minded i want
them to challenge me i want to challenge
them and sometimes it gets really heated
you know as a dad when you're leading at
such a crusade as i'm sure you'd call it
um about free thinking and free speech
and these kinds of things
surely
there's some kind of consequence for
your kids right because you're put not i
mean fame
in and of itself creates a consequence
for you they get picked on because
they're my dad but i always say to them
you also get lots of benefits because
you're my sons right and my children all
of you right we go and have a we have a
wonderful time right we get treated like
royalty in restaurants we you know we
have lovely holidays we have a lovely
place in beverly hills they come to all
this is because
of
my
fame for one of a better word and
success as amid the failings
and i say you got to take life in
totality there'll be some annoying bits
of being my
children and there'll be some very good
benefits of being my children you know i
got cristiano ronaldo when i interviewed
him to do a uh video to my sons naming
them all right they were like oh my god
but they wouldn't get that if i wasn't
who i am so they have a wonderful moment
and then they might get trolls as in one
case happen making death threats to my
oldest son on his instagram and i did
take that to the police because why
should my sons be exposed to death
threats from some disgusting troll and
it's interesting with the process it's
been over a year now and it still hasn't
come to court it was a clear and
demonstrable death threat specific
to my son and me and to his mum my
ex-wife and it's like how can this be
allowed to happen and we're still a year
a year and a half later and we're still
no action against the perpetrator i'm
hoping there will be it's going through
the process but shows you the frailty
and weakness of social media that
someone can make a specific death threat
and nothing gets done for so long so
that's a downside of being
my you know when in the good morning
britain thing blew up all my sons were
being abused on social media in the most
horrific manner by a targeted mob
of people normally who have the be kind
hashtag in their bio
while spewing vile abuse of my kids
simply for being my children they didn't
even agree with me about a lot of it
outside of losing people
when does pierce morgan cry
nafta
i mean really
the last time i cried was my
grandmother's funeral 2013.
before that
i remember welling up at a movie um i
was trying to i think it was it was a
movie that ends in a horrible fashion
with a young son being shot dead i can't
remember what each one it was um
i think it was paul tom hanks maybe
paul newman or something like i can't
remember the movie but i was at the
cinema i was watching it and
it reminded me of my sons
and when the kid gets killed in the kind
of horrible denis montes movie i did
actually well up and i was surprised i
learned normally i don't well up at most
things because i think also as a
newspaper relative for 10 years you get
quite immune to shocking things
even if they're real in your world you
get immune to it you get used to dealing
with you know you've had to
cover stories like the dumb lane
massacre or 911 or
diners death or whatever it may be these
things are huge emotional things for the
country for the world
and over time you learn to be able to
handle that and do your job so you
become quite tough
quite thick-skinned on the outside
doesn't mean you have to feel things
inside i do that's what i'm curious
about because reading through what
you've been through in your career the
ups and the downs i was like if i was
this man i would have had suffered with
anxiety pretty badly i think i don't get
anxiety do you ever get anxious no never
not really no i don't i don't get
nervous i don't get anxious i'm very
self-confident i think i'm pretty
self-aware which i think is really
important
i'm i'm very aware of who i am what i am
how i operate
i'm also aware over time the things that
seem terrible in the moment very rarely
are
everything is survivable apart from
death or
you know some sort of terrible illness
that you can't get rid of um you know
the most frustrated i've probably ever
been was i got long covered uh last year
after i got the
delta varium so i had a week of very
high fever and stuff then got six seven
months of long cove no smell no taste
endless fatigue no energy which for me
was like the worst thing you know i
broke an ankle the summer before and i
didn't mind that too much it was
annoying physically
i couldn't do golf and stuff like that
but i was able to function as myself but
when you lose energy it's a really
interesting thing i i found that really
debilitating and in a way quite
depressing you know over time as the
months went on because no doctor could
tell you what the cure is and i have
great sympathy with all the millions of
people out there with a form of long
covert it's a very brutal virus even if
you've been as i was fully vaccinated it
can cause you a lot of problems
but as i sat there month after month
after month with the energy not coming
back and no taste couldn't drink my
favorite fine wine only drink terrible
wine because the sharp tastes i could
actually just about make out so you're
down to your leapfrown emotion
really awful pinot grigio as opposed to
my normal you know chateau la tour it
was a it was a difficult moment
stop wallowing these are first world
problems and i am wallowing um
but it made me realize that if you've
got good health
you've got
a wealth really
far better than any actual physical
wealth that really if you've got your
health make the most of it i've got a
lot of sympathy for people who have
debilitating illnesses either mental or
physical that's why i always try and
debate about mental health to park the
two things i know people who've got
clinical depression it's an awful thing
and they need constant help and constant
medical attention and treatment and
drugs and so on i've got great sympathy
for people in that position in a way
when i had the long covid it it felt
like i guess this sort of brain fog that
comes with it which anyone who's had it
will know what i'm talking about if you
don't you just wonder what the fuzz is
all about but you get this kind of brain
fog that sits in your head and i'd
imagine that it's on a much worse level
for people with clinical depression i
can kind of understand a bit more now
about what that must feel like but
that's not the same as feeling anxious
about normal life stuff
it's the levels of anxiety completely
out of control so i don't get anxious
about things i don't get nervous about
stuff i get excited
i get that kind of adrenaline
excitement excitement nervous excitement
pierce morgan uncensored tell me then
why how are you finding your excitement
in doing this having had such a long
career what is it about this new show
that's exciting you it's brand new it's
starting from scratch i had lots of
offers to establish shows established
networks around the world and i thought
you know what i like this idea i like
going back to work for rupert murdoch
he's been a great mentor for me in my
life he's 91 i dinner with him here in
la a couple of nights ago and he just
his brain at 91 is just staggering and
his extraordinary drive to always be
thinking of the next thing he's just
been down to spacex and was in so
enthused by what elon musk is doing with
that he never looks back he just only
ever looks forward it's very contagious
and he believes completely in free
speech and it's made him a very
polarizing figure himself as it has with
me but he believes completely in that
and i find that intoxicated so going
back to where it started with the person
who gave me my first really big media
job uh with a global platform so no
one's really tried doing a daily show
that airs in the uk the us and australia
three different continents at the same
time and my gut feeling is the world's a
small place with debena that actually
we've got to a place now where because
of social media
whether you're in sydney london new york
you're all having the same arguments
everyone's talking about the will smith
slap or ukraine and zolensky and putin
or trump whatever it may be it's the
same conversations the same people being
held around the world and i think what
people want to know is not what's
happening because they're seeing that
all the time they're getting an overload
of information they want to know what to
think about it and i'm in the opinion
business i'm going to tell people what i
think about stuff i don't expect you to
agree with me
but i do want to challenge what you may
be thinking yourself i want to be firm
about what i believe about situations
and if you want to persuade me i'm wrong
come on i'm going to have people from
the left from the right i don't want to
be a partisan show i don't park myself
into the right or left at all
i think i'm a voice for common sense i
see it i don't actually think i'm that
controversial in terms of my opinions i
think anyone who read my book knows that
i think i'm pretty much on the side of
the 80 majority in most places but it's
going to be a challenge and it you know
i'm hoping it will work i'll give it
everything i've got and it's a big big
challenge probably the biggest i've ever
had but i find that exciting i love
starting from scratch brand new studio
we built an ealing out of rubble
literally out of concrete slabs we built
this amazing high-tech studio um i've
just been on a global tour to australia
to america and it was so exciting the
energy that i was getting everywhere
about this it's a lot of
support from this massive company to
make it work but ultimately it's the
wayne rescue thing maybe i'll miss
we'll see
but it won't be through lack of trying
and it won't be through lack of
confidence and it won't be through lack
of self-belief that i have that this is
the right show for the right moment
the public wants someone to cancel
cancel culture and because of what
happened with good morning britain i
became for better or for worse
a very public defender of free speech
and the right to have an opinion and
that will be the core of my show and
we've got to get back to that i think
it's a war
and i think cancer culture is a virus as
deadly over time as a coronavirus it
really is the damage it can do to
society i think is extremely serious and
it's getting worse not better and i want
to cancel it and what could be a better
legacy than the man
who canceled cancer culture
pierce thank you um you know as you can
tell you know there's much we agree on
there's some things we don't agree on as
well i followed trump not because i
agree with everything he says but
because i don't want to be trapped in an
echo chamber of people that are just
telling me things that i already believe
and there's this quote i read one day
which really resonated with me which is
if your friends have the same opinions
of you they're probably not your
opinions yeah but i would say my own
kids are like that yeah they don't agree
with a lot of the things they agree with
a lot of things as well but they also
understand the perils of this culture
that we're going down this slippery path
and they understand actually how
important this debate is
to get back to where we used to be with
debate it is we have a closing tradition
on this podcast always where the
previous guest writes a question for the
next question ah they don't know who
they're writing it for okay and you
won't either but um the question that's
been written for you is
okay interesting so i don't ever get to
read it tony jack reads it slope in the
book what advice would you give to your
five-year-old
self
just live exactly the dream you're
currently dreaming
good bad and ugly warts and all
find something you're passionate about
and at five i was passionate about news
i don't know why i can't explain it
but i was
and so i pursued a path of wanting to be
in the news
business
and it's been the greatest
journey
i could ever have imagined
good and bad
i wouldn't change any of it nothing so
my advice to five-year-old peers would
be yep go for it
there you have it thank you pierce thank
you really enjoyed it appreciate it
[Music]
[Music]